on va plus loin avec françois durpaire
historien qui sera avec tout dans un
instant et vous gauthier rybinski
bonjourbonjour emmanuel macron l'a donc
annoncé la france se retire du mali avec
ses alliés européens écouter
la france et ses partenaires engagés
dans des missions de lutte contre le
terrorisme à savoir les états
participant à la task force takouba ont
pris la décision de retirer leur
présence militaire au mali voilà qui
sonne le glas de plus de neuf années
d'engagement un plus que toute autre
intervention militaire française depuis
la guerre d'algérie écoutez comment
emmanuel macron justifie sa décision
la france est intervenue au mali
premièrement pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
deuxièmement à la demande d'un état
souverain et des états de la région
c'est cette deuxième condition qui
change aujourd'hui et la victoire face
au terrorisme elle n'est pas possible si
elle n'est pas portée par l'état
lui-même
et pourquoi nous décidons aujourd'hui de
partir parce que
la junte qui est en responsabilité au
mali n'ont fait plus sa priorité la
junte n'en fait plus sa priorité
françois durpaire alors quelle est la
vraie raison de ce départ la dérive
autoritaire du mal ou bien le mépris
supposé des nouvelles autorités
maliennes pour la lutte anti djihadistes
en gros la morale ou l'efficacité et
vous mettez de côté l'élection française
le fait de ne pas avoir une image
catastrophique cette guerre c'est c'est
la nature de guerre de qui ne sont pas
perdus militairement mais qui ne peuvent
pas être gagner politiquement c'est pas
la première du genre les américains les
connaissent et guerre l'irak
l'afghanistan
ce sont ces guerres asymétriques qui
sont impossibles à gagner et pourquoi
parce qu'au coeur il yal'image alors
même s'il ya des victoires militaires
même s'il ya des gains territoriaux même
s'il ya des chefs djihadistes qui qui
sont tués et bien finalement
concrètement l'image qu'il en ressort
c'est cette junte militaire c'est ce
double coup d'état et c'est finalement
cette france avec deux choses d'abord
les images antilles françaises qui
peuvent être catastrophiques dans ce
cadre électoral vous rappeler que byden
sa chute de popularité il s'en est
toujours pas remis de ce qui s'est passé
fin août pour lui et en afghanistan et
en afghanistan on parle de l'afghanistan
et des images de kaboul on peut pas ne
pas penser que dans l'entourage des
manuels macron se disent il faut
absolument qu'ils aient pas ce type
d'image avant les élections et puis la
deuxième chose c'est que non seulement
il peut y avoir des images antilles
françaises mais il ya aussi des images
de dégradations géopolitique puisque la
france est remplacé par des mercenaires
russes et ces images là vous les avez
vécu la semaine dernière c'est cette
conférence de presse entre emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine ou ses
journalistes posent la question et deux
fois parce que la réponse n'est pas venu
quid des mercenaires russes qu'est ce
qui se passe questions posées à vladmir
poutine questions posées à emmanuel
macron et ça fait quand même mauvais
genre c'est donc donc là vous avez
remarqué quand même quelque chose c'est
que dans la communication il est très
important de ne pas être intervenu seul
en afrique mais il est surtout très
important
de ne pas faire un retrait sérieux de ne
pas partir seul de ne pas partir seul et
de dire c'est l'union européenne c'est
le canada et on va voilà recomposée nos
forces et surtout aussi de se projeter
positivement en donnant des éléments de
communication en ce sens dressant dans
le motif quand même initial de cette
intervention la lutte contre le
djihadisme est ce qu'on ne risque pas
gauthier rybinski de faire du mali un
sanctuaire du jihadisme une base de
repli pour ces mouvements qui s'étend
désormais à au sud 1 jusqu'au golfe de
guinée et en laissant à notamment les
mains libres à la junte malienne y
compris de négocier avait été déjà dit
si elle le souhaite si probablement et
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
c'est ce que vient de dire françois
durpaire quand on intervient
militairement avec l'idée que l'on peut
se suffire à soi-même pour créer une
nation ce qu'on appelle nation building
de deux choses l'une soit ça marche pas
du tout soit au contraire c'est même pas
au contraire c'est la catastrophe il n'y
a pas 36 manières d'y échapper donc là
ça voulait dire tout simplement que si
on voulait arriver à quelque chose il
fallait se donner les moyens on le fait
un peu tardivement avec l'europe mais
pour répondre à votre question bien sûr
que c'est un moyen pour le djia de se
donner des ailes puisqu'au fond on peut
très bien imaginer avec la junte un
partage des territoires de toute manière
l'état malien n'a jamais quel qu'il soit
n'a jamais poussé un peu plus haut que
un certain parallèle qui le sépare de
toute manière de gao de sa lite et c'est
donc ça veut dire qui peut très bien y
avoir une sorte d'accord de finalement
de la grue mante entre le djihad qui lui
vide les villages c'est peut-être là
qu'on peut s'entendre entre la jeune ne
pu vider les villages pour les
djihadistes serait en sorte qu'ils
seraient admis par une junte qui en plus
n'a pas les moyens militaires de
combattre ces djihadistes donc voilà il
ya les ingrédients effectivement le
retrait et les ingrédients interne au
mali pour qu'il y ait une sorte
d'arrangement et les mains libres comme
vous disais aux djihadistes la france en
tout cas tirer les enseignements du mali
les réactions d'hostilité d'une partie
de la population notamment voici comment
emmanuel macron entrevoit la poursuite
de l'engagement français au sahel
il nous n'avons pas ce sonore mais
emmanuel macron qui voit là a évoqué la
le ils ont le leur et leur déploiement
des forces françaises dans la région ça
vous semble plus raisonnable d'envisager
notamment le niger françois durpaire
réaliste ou bien la france se heurtera
tôt ou tard finalement aux mêmes
difficultés ailleurs qu'au mali car
comme on a pu raconter ce qu'il a dit ce
qu'il a expliqué c'est que pas du tout
c'est pas une d'un oh là on la regarde
on part dont il est avec nous désolé
franchement on va l'écouter
sur le sonar est avec nous recentrer sur
demande de nos partenaires là où notre
contribution est attendue toujours en
soutien et encore davantage intégrés
comme nous le sommes au niger avec les
forces armées de la région nous
définirons dans les semaines et mois qui
viennent l'appui que nous apporterons à
chacun des pays de la région sur la base
des besoins qui seront exprimés
cet appui pour inclure de l'aide en
matière de formation et d'entraînement
de la fourniture d'équipements voir un
appui à leurs opérations contre le
terrorisme françois pardon de vous avoir
interrompu alors est ce que ça va
changer quelque chose c'est un peu le
cache sexe du retrait est là on est en
train de dire non non pas du tout on se
retire pas pas du tout c'est pas un
fiasco c'est pas c'est pas un échec même
ça a été dit mais emmanuel macron a dit
ce n'est pas un échec c'est juste un
redéploiement c'est quand même un échec
de la politique française au mali c'est
de dire effectivement d'abord on va
devoir fermer quatre à six mois pour
fermer gossip ménaka et gao ensuite
redéploiement au niger notamment avec
une base aérienne qui est déjà une base
française avec 800 soldats français mais
redéploiement vers le niger et ensuite
avec un meilleur accueil à priori en
tout cas si on est si l'on écoute le
soleil inonde et là c'était important
l'image l'image du président français
entouré des trois présidents africains
et c'est aussi de se dire on va avoir
une stratégie plus vaste
on reprend sans le citer la stratégie
finalement de georges canam défini vous
savez la fameuse endiguement que les
américains avaient défini contre le
communisme là c'est contre le djihadisme
c'est le côté de mingue l'endiguement
contrôle jihadistes pour pas que ceux
des indices pousse vers le golfe de
guinée et donc on va ouvrir de nouveaux
partenariats d'où l'importance de
l'image et renforcer le partenariat avec
le sénégal notamment avec la côte
d'ivoire et là c'est très important
d'avoir en même temps toutes les
interventions de ses chefs d'état que
d'ivoire bénin également et sénégal
puisqu'il ya eu le discours de macky
sall aujourd'hui donc c'est cette
stratégie là qu on redéfinit toujours
pour dire ben voilà il n'y a pas de
retrait c'est simplement une
redéfinition notre politique dans
l'ouest de l'afrique ses partenaires
africains qui serrent les rangs
aujourd'hui des airs la france on
imagine bien que c'est important bien
sûr mais au delà des communications et
ce qu'ils sont aptes demain à lutter eux
contre le djihadisme si la france réduit
la voilure ce qui semble être le cas en
tout cas en nombre de soldats problème
c'est que les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets parfois et que au fond
si on regarde l'histoire du mali où
d'autres qu'est ce qui a facilité la
pénétration du jihadisme et sa
progression c'est bien des effets
internes c'est bien des querelles des
dissensions de déchirures internes et
celles là elles sont tout autant
existantes quand on descend justement en
allant vers le vert le golfe de guinée
parce que vous avez des antécédents qui
sont à la fois deux confrontations
religieuses lorsque
le chef touareg agra les voilà rallye
avait indiqué qu'il fallait poursuivre
le djihad justement vers le golfe de
guinée il avait incité les peules par
exemple à se joindre à ce combat en dix
ans finalement vous êtes des ddd soutien
vous êtes la lame de l'islam dans cette
région il faut que vous rejoignez le
combat est donc à partir de là si vous
voulez c'est pour ça que je disais les
mêmes causes produisant les mêmes effets
la fragilité de ces sociétés là du golfe
de guinée
réclament quelque chose d'autre que si
ce n'est dans la méthode du moins dans
le fond pour agir plutôt que de
reproduire ce qui s'est passé au mali
par exemple au burkina
vérifier on se fait taxer nation
building avec quand même des
particularités locales nationales très
très forte on peut pas comparer
notamment l'islam au mali et cet islam
sénégalais de confréries extrêmement
puissant et un islam nationale vous
appartenez à une confrérie c'est très
difficile quand un djihadiste arrive et
c'est d'exporter une vision de l'islam
alors que j'allais dire de manière
extrêmement trivial les gens sont bien
dans leurs baskets et bien dans leur
confrérie donc ça veut dire que on va
pas nécessairement avoir d'ici un an
deux ans trois ans ce qui s'est passé au
mali avec des particularités locales
extrêmement
spécifique
historique entre le nord et le sud du
pays s'ouvrit certaine déception de
rennes justement où ce que vous disiez
un instant quand on est bien dans son
islam sénégalais on va pas regarder un
islam wahhabite puissions aussi du
développement quête voilà importante
s'il ya émergence des classes moyennes
si tout sur le plan est donc ça fait
beaucoup de si fier bien sûr bien sûr
mais il faut regarder justement l'état
de ces sociétés et l'état de
développement des réseaux ni d'où
l'enjeu du sommet union afflux
partenariat ibm pour qu' il y ait des
milliards d'euros de dépenses et dans ce
développement et pour que cette aide au
développement de l'afrique soit une aide
au développement intelligente samho
dream en gouvernementale va au delà des
mots aujourd'hui cet effort lès laval
offre européenne puisqu'on évoque
effectivement des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliards d'euros alors ça
va au delà des mots il faudrait pas
penser uniquement en terme de bien sûr
il faut des milliards d'euros mais il
faut aussi repenser de manière
intelligente c'était de développement ça
veut dire que ne peut pas être
strictement gouvernementales et doit
intégrer quand on dit la société civile
ça veut dire qu'ils les organisations
non gouvernementales qui connaissent le
terrain et qui sont à même concrètement
de dire voilà ce qui peut poser problème
dans un certain nombre de domaines les
individus les familles esclave étant
déferré macouin que le sommet de
montpellier le sommet où on a intégré la
société il mais il faut le faire
n'excluant du coup les chefs d'état bien
sûr mais c'est pas seulement de trois
intellectuels africains c'est vraiment
par exemple les familles c'est pas
uniquement j'avais bien l'élite de ces
sociétés en diaspora c'est aussi d'aider
des gens très modeste qui contribuent au
développement de leur village de leur
région et ça c'est très important de les
intégrer est ce que ces familles là ils
ont sont intégrés dans le sommet union
africaine union européenne ses passions
on les voit pas et pourtant elle
contribue au développement et à savent
exactement où il ya besoin d'ouvrir une
école où il ya besoin de scolariser les
enfants où il ya des problèmes
spécifiques de santé où il se pose ce
que font les organisations non
gouvernementales et pas forcément les
crocs organisé dans c'est souvent du
microcrédit voilà en ce moment par
exemple vous avez une émergence de deux
petites associations de gens issus de la
diaspora par exemple en france par
exemple en italie par exemple en
belgique qui participent qui ouvre une
école ici qui participent à la rentrée
scolaire la qui participent à la mise en
place d'un dispensaire dans telle région
parce que les parents souvent d'ailleurs
d'enfants français qui ne connaissent
pas nécessairement très très bien le
pays d'origine de leurs parents mais qui
vite s'investir ces gens là doivent
faire partie de la stratégie de
partenariat mise en place par l'union
européenne en afrique on est loin des
mécanismes effectivement interétatique
qui pose aussi d'ailleurs la question de
la conditionnalité que pose l'europe un
certain nombre de dettes ce n'est pas le
cas on le sait de la chine et de la
russie beaucoup moins regardante quand
on voit même wagner qui assure
aujourd'hui une assurance vie un certain
nombre de régimes à commencer par le
mali ce qui apparaît ce que ça fasse
tache d'huile en afrique de l'ouest là
aussi au détriment de la france et des
européens peut-être plus regardants oui
plus regardants même temps si vous
prenez le nigeria l'europe n'est pas
très méchante avec le nigéria pas ce qui
est du pétrole là on est si tu veux si
vous voulez on est dans deux extrêmes le
premier extrême c'était de dire
effectivement l'action militaire pur et
simple
la boutique a pas grand chose mais quand
on prend la question du côté européen en
dix ans la conditionnalité donc qui
dirige les fonds en fonction de la vertu
démocratique des gouvernements si on
reste uniquement dans le domaine civil
c'est pareil on aboutit à pas
grand-chose parce qu'une junte au
pouvoir même si vous apportez les vertus
justement du microcrédit de l'aide
locale si la junte qui est au pouvoir
est capable de capter un certain nombre
de fronts de fond ou de continuer à
s'enrichir par la contrebande votre
bonne volonté elle fond comme neige au
soleil en a pas beaucoup et comme
véritablement elle est étouffé par les
mener politique ça veut dire que une
aide quelle qu'elle soit elle est à la
fois je peux pas dire à tous les coups
mais en théorie militaire avec du civil
et un programme civil de qui me
corresponde à la conditionnelle dans
quelqu'un ya besoin d'un état de droit
et d'un climat des affaires entre
guillemets pour pouvoir aider
directement celui compris s'il n'y a pas
cet état de droit on en revient au cas
de figure que signaler tout à l'heure
françois durpaire propos du sénégal si
les choses se passent bien avec l'islam
sénégalais c'est parce qu'il ya un
relatifs bien-être bien-être de la part
des musulmans au sénégal s'ils sont
frustrés un jour par un état qui soit
soucieuse en gouvernant soir là il ya
des chances qu'ils se jettent dans une
autre formule donc les deux
effectivement sont complémentaires merci
gauthier merci également à vous françois
durpaire c'est la fin on va plus loin